I'm writing every Devil's fruit in one
piece to figure out which is the best
one this is the Mochi mochino meat which
grants the user the ability to produce
and transform their body into delicious
Mochi this fruit was eaten by katakuri
the strongest of big mom's children and
in terms of strength allows the user to
stretch their limbs create slaming Spike
donuts and even summoning a ridiculous
number of fists to pound enemies 23 out
of 25 points for defense the user can
shift their yummy body around any attack
so a massive 23 points for defense as
well as for special abilities it's
basically like two devil fruits combined
into one since the user's body is
transformed and they can produce Mochi
as well another 23 points and it's also
an incredibly useful devil fruit for
everyday use you can create literally
anything that you want only that it's
made out of Mochi 18 points here however
since Mochi is not the most durable
substance and can be eaten I'm going to
subtract 8 points for weaknesses
bringing its total to a truly impressive
79 points which puts its second place on
our list for now